hi i'm andrew garfield and these are my
five favorite movie musicals the first
one that comes to mind is bugsy malone
which is an alan parker film musical
of
young gangsters
who are 12 13 years old who are shooting
each other with custard pies it sounds
weird but it
it is but it's also incredible and the
songs are incredible
jodie foster plays tallulah
um you have this wonderful character
fizzy who played who sings one of my
favorite songs in it called tomorrow
he's bought he wants to be a dancer but
he's he's he's just like he mops the
floor at the fat sam's grand slam club
it's just like there's another song
called um so you want to be a boxer
which is just oh my god and then the
final song which i want played at my
wedding is my first dance at my wedding
if i ever have a wedding
uh which is um we could have been
anything that we wanted to be and it's
so it's just great yeah i love that film
it's an allen parker film and he makes
mostly
so many he's made so many weird movies
like angel heart and then bugs him alone
doesn't make any sense he was genius
number two would probably be singing in
the rain
just because it's singing in the rain
and it's just just pure
movie magic and musical movie magic and
the the numbers are some of the best
dance numbers you'll ever witness make
them laugh
and of course the classic singing in the
rain which tom holland has immortalized
forevermore
um with his um umbrella um singing in
the rain mashup
um
yeah so singing in the rain coming in
hot number two this is controversial
i love greece too
it's weird
i know it's weird
cool writer
we're gonna score tonight
the bowling song
shouldn't uh you know and let's do it
for our country which is kind of a
really problematic song at this point
but that actor i forget his name um an
amazing musical theater actor i totally
i'm blanking on his name but i'm
obsessed with him who plays damucci um
anyway it's i and michelle pfeiffer just
on top of a ladder pretending she's on
the back of a motor it's all it's all
good it's all wonderful number four i'm
gonna i'm gonna go in the heights like i
i watched it in a theater with josh
henry and robin dejesus in the middle of
shooting take take boom during covert
lynn got us the theater for the three of
us josh henry and robin have both been
in the show have a history with the show
so i'm watching with these two legends
who are having the most personal
interaction with this film of the
musical that they know so well
and i am experiencing it so fresh
and just like
falling in love with lin manuel miranda
all over again and with anthony ramos
and that whole company
and john chu and alice brooks who shot
off phil also shot that like it's
it's a master class in epic scope joy
and storytelling and heart and i was
like i have to i wanted to be
i wanted to be that i wanted to pour out
into the streets i wanted to start
dancing you know with josh and robin but
we had to go back to our quarantines it
was so painful like i was just so full
of that kind of
that that spirit the spirit of that film
and i'm just such a huge fan
so number five would be fred astaire in
the bandwagon which i was introduced to
by lin-manuel miranda and it's again
it's got some of my favorite dance
numbers in it and it's it's synopsis is
so silly i'm not even gonna say it
because you should all just watch it and
trust me that it's just so beautiful so
joyful it's very show busy
and very heartfelt and like it's a love
story it's just gorgeous and the dark
and he just i could watch him dance
i could just watch him dance forever so
there you go
[Music]
you